we know humans learn from their past
experiences
and machines follow instructions given
by humans
but what if humans can train the
machines to learn from the past data and
do what humans can do and much faster
well that's called machine learning but
it's a lot more than just learning it's
also about understanding and reasoning
so today we will learn about the basics
of machine learning
so that's paul he loves listening to new
songs
he either likes them or dislikes them
paul decides this on the basis of the
song's tempo
genre
intensity and the gender of voice for
simplicity let's just use tempo and
intensity for now so here tempo is on
the x-axis ranging from relaxed to fast
whereas intensity is on the y-axis
ranging from light to soaring we see
that paul likes the song with fast tempo
and soaring intensity while he dislikes
the song with relaxed tempo and light
intensity so now we know paul's choices
let's say paul listens to a new song
let's name it as song a song a has fast
tempo and a soaring intensity so it lies
somewhere here looking at the data can
you guess whether paul will like the
song or not correct so paul likes this
song by looking at paul's past choices
we were able to classify the unknown
song very easily right let's say now
paul listens to a new song let's label
it as song p so song b
lies somewhere here with medium tempo
and medium intensity neither relaxed nor
fast neither light nor soaring now can
you guess whether paul likes it or not
not able to guess whether paul will like
it or dislike it are the choices unclear
correct we could easily classify song a
but when the choice became complicated
as in the case of song b yes and that's
where machine learning comes in let's
see how in the same example for song b
if we draw a circle around the song b we
see that there are four votes for like
whereas one would for dislike if we go
for the majority votes we can say that
paul will definitely like the song
that's all this was a basic machine
learning algorithm also it's called k
nearest neighbors so this is just a
small example in one of the many machine
learning algorithms quite easy right
believe me it is but what happens when
the choices become complicated as in the
case of song b that's when machine
learning comes in it learns the data
builds the prediction model and when the
new data point comes in it can easily
predict for it more the data better the
model higher will be the accuracy there
are many ways in which the machine
learns it could be either supervised
learning unsupervised learning or
reinforcement learning let's first
quickly understand supervised learning
suppose your friend gives you one
million coins of three different
currencies say one rupee one euro and
one dirham each coin has different
weights for example a coin of one rupee
weighs three grams one euro weighs seven
grams and one dirham weighs four grams
your model will predict the currency of
the coin here your weight becomes the
feature of coins while currency becomes
the label when you feed this data to the
machine learning model it learns which
feature is associated with which label
for example it will learn that if a coin
is of 3 grams it will be a 1 rupee coin
let's give a new coin to the machine on
the basis of the weight of the new coin
your model will predict the currency
hence supervised learning uses labeled
data to train the model here the machine
knew the features of the object and also
the labels associated with those
features on this note let's move to
unsupervised learning and see the
difference suppose you have cricket data
set of various players with their
respective scores and wickets taken when
you feed this data set to the machine
the machine identifies the pattern of
player performance so it plots this data
with the respective wickets on the
x-axis while runs on the y-axis while
looking at the data you'll clearly see
that there are two clusters the one
cluster are the players who scored high
runs and took less wickets while the
other cluster is of the players who
scored less runs but took many wickets
so here we interpret these two clusters
as batsmen and bowlers the important
point to note here is that there were no
labels of batsmen and bowlers hence the
learning with unlabeled data is
unsupervised learning so we saw
supervised learning where the data was
labeled and the unsupervised learning
where the data was unlabeled and then
there is reinforcement learning which is
reward based learning or we can say that
it works on the principle of feedback
here let's say you provide the system
with an image of a dog and ask it to
identify it the system identifies it as
a cat so you give a negative feedback to
the machine saying that it's a dog's
image the machine will learn from the
feedback and finally if it comes across
any other image of a dog it will be able
to classify it correctly that is
reinforcement learning to generalize
machine learning model let's see a
flowchart input is given to a machine
learning model which then gives the
output according to the algorithm
applied if it's right we take the output
as a final result else we provide
feedback to the training model and ask
it to predict until it learns i hope
you've understood supervised and
unsupervised learning so let's have a
quick quiz you have to determine whether
the given scenarios uses supervised or
unsupervised learning simple right
scenario one facebook recognizes your
friend in a picture from an album of
tagged photographs
scenario 2 netflix recommends new movies
based on someone's past movie choices
scenario 3 analyzing bank data for
suspicious transactions and flagging the
fraud transactions think wisely and
comment below your answers moving on
don't you sometimes wonder how is
machine learning possible in today's era
well that's because today we have
humongous data available everybody is
online either making a transaction or
just surfing the internet and that's
generating a huge amount of data every
minute and that data my friend is the
key to analysis also the memory handling
capabilities of computers have largely
increased which helps them to process
such huge amount of data at hand without
any delay and yes computers now have
great computational powers so there are
a lot of applications of machine
learning out there to name a few machine
learning is used in health care where
diagnostics are predicted for doctor's
review the sentiment analysis that the
tech giants are doing on social media is
another interesting application of
machine learning fraud detection in the
finance sector and also to predict
customer churn in the e-commerce sector
while booking a gap you must have
encountered search pricing often where
it says the fare of your trip has been
updated continue booking yes please i'm
getting late for office well that's an
interesting machine learning model which
is used by global taxi giant uber and
others where they have differential
pricing in real time based on demand the
number of cars available bad weather
rush r etc so they use the search
pricing model to ensure that those who
need a cab can get one also it uses
predictive modeling to predict where the
demand will be high with the goal that
drivers can take care of the demand and
search pricing can be minimized great
hey siri can you remind me to book a cab
at 6 00 pm today okay i'll remind you
thanks no problem comment below some
interesting everyday examples around you
where machines are learning and doing
amazing jobs what's in it for you today
well we'll start off with a brief
explanation of why machine learning and
what is machine learning and then we'll
get into a few of the types of machine
learning machine learning algorithms
linear regression decision trees support
vector machine and finally we'll do a
use case where we're going to classify
whether recipe is of a cupcake or a
muffin using the svm or the support
vector machine sounds like a delicious
way to explore machine learning so why
machine learning why do we even care
about having these computers come up and
be able to do all these new things for
us
well because machines can now drive your
car for you still very in the infant
stage but it's just exploding as we see
with google's waymo and then uberhead
their program which unfortunately
crashed
they know that this is huge this is
going to be the huge industry to change
our whole transportation infrastructure
machine learning is now used to detect
over 50 eye diseases do you know how
amazing that is to have a computer that
double checks for the doctor for things
they might miss that's just huge in the
health industry pretty soon they
actually do already have that within
some areas where maybe not for eyes but
for other diseases where they're using
the camera on your phone to help
pre-diagnose before you go in and see
the doctor and because the machine can
now unlock your phone with your face i
mean that's just cool having it being
able to identify your face or your voice
and be able to turn stuff on and off for
you depending on where you're at and
what you need talking about an ultimate
automation their world we live in and as
we dig in deeper we have a nice example
of facebook as you can see here they
have the facebook post with halloween
comment yes if you want it order here
nobody likes spam post on facebook that
annoy them into interacting with likes
shares comments and other actions i
remember the original ones were all if
you don't click on here you will have
bad luck or some kind of fear factor
well this is a huge thing in a social
media when people are getting spammed
and so this tactic known as engagement
bait takes advantage of facebook's news
feed algorithm by choosing engagement in
order to get the greater reach to
eliminate engagement bait the company
reviewed and categorized hundreds of
thousands of posts to train a machine
learning model that detects different
types of engagement bait so in this case
we have we're using facebook but this is
of course across all the different
social media they have different tools
for building and the facebook scroll
jiff will be replaced kind of like a
virus coming in there and notices that
there's a certain setup with facebook
and it's able to replace it and they
have like vote baiting react baiting
share baiting they have all these
different these are kind of general
titles but there certainly are a lot of
way of baiting you to go in there and
click on something so they fed all this
this data was fed into the machine and
then they have the new post the new post
comes up that takes over part of the
facebook setup and that's what you're
looking at you're looking at this new
post that's replaced like a virus has
replaced that so what facebook do to
eliminate this is they start scanning
for keywords and phrases like this and
checks the click-through rate so it
starts looking for people who are
clicking through it without even looking
at it or clicking through it and it's
not something that normally would be
clicked through once facebook has
scanned for these keywords and phrases
it is now able to identify the spam
coming in and this makes your life
easier so you're not getting spammed
it's not like walking through an airport
and a lot of countries you have like
hundreds of people trying to sell you
timeshare come join us sign up for this
eliminates that annoyingness so now you
can just enjoy your facebook and your
cat pictures or maybe it's your family
pictures mine is family certainly people
like their cat pictures too another good
example is google's deepmind project
alphago a computer program that plays a
board game go has defeated the world's
number one go player and i hope i say
his name right kiji the ultimate go
challenge game of three of three was on
may 27 2017. so it's just last year that
this happened and what makes this so
important is that you know go is just is
a game so it's not like you're driving a
car or something in our real world but
they are using games to learn how to get
the machine learning program to learn
they want it to learn how to learn and
that is a huge step a lot of this is
still in its infant stage as far as
development as we saw what happened with
the as i referred to earlier the uber
cars they lost their whole division
because they jumped ahead too fast so
it's still an infant stage but boy is
this like the beginning of just an
amazing world that is automated in ways
we can't even imagine what tomorrow's
going to look like we've looked at a lot
of examples of machine learning so let's
see if we can give a little bit more of
a concrete definition
what is machine learning machine
learning is the science of making
computers learn and act like humans by
feeding data and information without
being explicitly programmed we see here
we have a nice little diagram where we
have our ordinary system and your
computer nowadays you can even run a lot
of stuff on a cell phone because cell
phones advance so much and then with
artificial intelligence and machine
learning it now takes the data and it
learns from what happened before and
then it predicts what's going to come
next and then really the biggest part
right now in machine learning that's
going on is it improves on that how do
we find a new solution so we go from
descriptive where it's learning about
stuff and understanding how it fits
together to predicting what it's going
to do to post scripting coming up with a
new solution and when we're working on
machine learning there's a number of
different diagrams that people have
posted for what steps to go through a
lot of it might be very domain specific
so if you're working on photo
identification versus language versus
medical or physics some of these are
switched around a little bit or new
things are put in they're very specific
to the domain this is kind of a very
general diagram first you want to define
your objective very important to know
what it is you're wanting to predict
then you're going to be collecting the
data so once you've defined an objective
you need to collect the data that
matches you spend a lot of time in data
science collecting data in the next step
preparing the data you got to make sure
that your data is clean going in there's
the old saying bad data in bad answer
out or bad data out
and then once you've gone through and
we've cleaned all this stuff coming in
then you're going to select the
algorithm which algorithm are you going
to use you're going to train that
algorithm in this case i think we're
going to be working with svm the support
vector machine then you have to test the
model does this model work is this a
valid model for what we're doing and
then once you've tested it you want to
run your prediction you want to run your
prediction or your choice or whatever
output it's going to come up with and
then once everything is set and you've
done lots of testing then you want to go
ahead and deploy the model remember i
said domain specific this is very
general as far as the scope of doing
something a lot of models you get
halfway through and you realize that
your data is missing something and you
have to go collect new data because
you've run a test in here someplace
along the line you're saying hey i'm not
really getting the answers i need so
there's a lot of things that are domain
specific that become part of this model
this is a very general model but it's a
very good model to start with and we do
have some basic divisions of what
machine learning does that's important
to know for instance do you want to
predict a category well if you're
categorizing thing that's classification
for instance whether the stock price
will increase or decrease so in other
words i'm looking for a yes no answer is
it going up or is it going down and in
that case we'd actually say is it going
up true if it's not going up it's false
meaning it's going down this way it's a
yes no zero one do you want to predict a
quantity that's regression so remember
we just did classification now we're
looking at regression these are the two
major divisions in what data is doing
for instance predicting the age of a
person based on the height weight health
and other factors so based on these
different factors you might guess how
old a person is
and then there are a lot of domain
specific
things like do you want to detect an
anomaly that's anomaly detection this is
actually very popular right now for
instance you want to detect money
withdrawal anomalies you want to know
when someone's making a withdrawal that
might not be their own account we've
actually brought this up because this is
really big right now if you're
predicting the stock whether to buy
stock or not you want to be able to know
if what's going on in the stock market
is an anomaly use a different prediction
model because something else is going on
you got to pull out new information in
there or is this just the norm i'm going
to get my normal return on my money
invested so being able to detect
anomalies is very big in data science
these days another question that comes
up which is on what we call untrained
data is do you want to discover
structure in unexplored data and that's
called clustering for instance finding
groups of customers with similar
behavior given a large database of
customer data containing their
demographics and past buying records and
in this case we might notice that
anybody who's wearing certain set of
shoes goes shopping at certain stores or
whatever it is they're going to make
certain purchases by having that
information it helps us to market or
group people together so that we can now
explore that group and find out what it
is we want to market to them if you're
in the marketing world and that might
also work in just about any arena you
might want to group people together
whether they're based on their different
areas and investments and financial
background whether you're going to give
them a loan or not before you even start
looking at whether they're a valid
customer for the bank you might want to
look at all these different areas and
group them together based on unknown
data so you're not you don't know what
the data is going to tell you but you
want to cluster people together that
come together
let's take a quick detour for
quiz time oh my favorite so we're going
to have a couple questions here under
quiz time
and we'll be posting the answers in this
part two of this tutorial so let's go
ahead and take a look at these quiz
times questions and hopefully you'll get
them all right it'll get you thinking
about how to process data and what's
going on can you tell what's happening
in the following cases of course you're
sitting there with your cup of coffee
and you have your checkbox and your pen
trying to figure out what's your next
step in your data science analysis
so the first one is grouping documents
into different categories based on the
topic and content of each document very
big these days
you know you have legal documents you
have maybe it's the sports group
documents maybe you're analyzing
newspaper postings
but certainly having that automated is a
huge thing in today's world
b identifying handwritten digits in
images correctly
so we want to know whether uh they're
writing an a or capital a b c
what are they writing out in their hand
digit their handwriting c behavior of a
website indicating that the site is not
working as designed d predicting salary
of an individual based on his or her
years of experience
hr hiring uh set up there so stay tuned
for part two we'll go ahead and answer
these questions when we get to the part
two of this tutorial or you can just
simply write at the bottom and send a
note to simply learn and they'll follow
up with you on it
back to our regular content now these
last few bring us into the next topic
which is another way of dividing our
types of machine learning and that is
with supervised unsupervised
and reinforcement learning supervised
learning is a method used to enable
machines to classify predict objects
problems or situations based on labeled
data fed to the machine and in here you
see we have a jungle of data with
circles triangles and squares then we
label them we have what's a circle
what's a triangle what's a square and we
have our model training and it trains it
so we know the answer very important
when you're doing supervised learning
you already know the answer to a lot of
your information coming in so you have a
huge group of data coming in and then
you have a new data coming in so we've
trained our model the model now knows
the difference between a circle a square
a triangle and now that we've trained it
we can send in in this case a square and
a circle goes in and it predicts that
the top one's a square and the next
one's a circle and you can see that this
is
being able to predict whether someone's
going to default on a loan because i was
talking about banks earlier supervised
learning on stock market whether you're
going to make money or not that's always
important and if you are looking to make
a fortune in the stock market keep in
mind it is very difficult to get all the
data correct on the stock market it is
very it fluctuates in ways you really
hard to predict so it's quite a roller
coaster ride if you're running machine
learning on the stock market you start
realizing you really have to dig for new
data so we have supervised learning and
if you have supervised we should need
unsupervised learning in unsupervised
learning machine learning model finds
the hidden pattern in an unlabeled data
so in this case instead of telling it
what the circle is what a triangle is
and what a square is it goes in there
looks at them and says for whatever
reason it groups them together maybe
they'll group it by the number of
corners and it notices that a number of
them all have three corners a number of
them all have four corners and a number
of them all have no corners and it's
able to filter those through and group
them together we talked about that
earlier with looking at a group of
people who are out shopping we want to
group them together to find out what
they have in common and of course once
you understand what people have in
common maybe you have one of them is a
customer at your store or you have five
of them our customer your store and they
have a lot in common with five others
who are not customers at your store how
do you market to those five who aren't
customers at your store yet they fit the
demographs of who's going to shop there
and you'd like them to shop at your
store not the one next door of course
this is a simplified version you can see
very easily the difference between a
triangle and a circle which might not be
so easy in marketing reinforcement
learning reinforcement learning is an
important type of machine learning where
an agent learns how to behave in an
environment by performing actions and
seeing the result we have here where the
in this case a baby it's actually great
that they used an infant for this slide
because the reinforcement learning is
very much in its infant stages but it's
also probably the biggest machine
learning demand out there right now or
in the future it's going to be coming up
over the next few years is reinforcement
learning and how to make that work for
us and you can see here where we have
our action in the action on this one it
goes into the fire hopefully the baby
didn't it's just a little candle not a
giant fire pit like it looks like here
when the baby comes out and the new
state is the baby is sad and crying
because they got burned on the fire and
then maybe they take another action the
baby's called the agent because it's the
one taking the actions and in this case
they didn't go into the fire they went a
different direction and now the baby's
happy and laughing and playing
reinforcement learning is very easy to
understand because that's how as humans
that's one of the ways we learn we learn
whether it is you bring yourself on the
stove don't do that anymore don't touch
the stove in the big picture being able
to have a machine learning program or an
ai be able to do this is huge because
now we're starting to learn how to learn
that's a big jump in the world of
computer and machine learning and we're
going to go back and just kind of go
back over supervised versus unsupervised
learning understanding this is huge
because this is going to come up in any
project you're working on we have in
supervised learning we have labeled data
we have direct feedback so someone's
already gone in there and said yes
that's a triangle no that's not a
triangle and then you predict an outcome
so you have a nice prediction this is
this this new set of data is coming in
and we know what it's going to be and
then with unsupervised training it's not
labeled so we really don't know what it
is there's no feedback so we're not
telling it whether it's right or wrong
we're not telling it whether it's a
triangle or a square we're not telling
it to go left or right all we do is
we're finding hidden structure in the
data grouping the data together to find
out what connects to each other and then
you can use these together so imagine
you have an image and you're not sure
what you're looking for so you go in and
you have the unstructured data find all
these things that are connected together
and then somebody looks at those and
labels them now you can take that label
data and program something to predict
what's in the picture so you can see how
they go back and forth and you can start
connecting all these different tools
together to make a bigger picture there
are many interesting machine learning
algorithms let's have a look at a few of
them hopefully this gives you a little
flavor what's out there and these are
some of the most important ones that are
currently being used we'll take a look
at linear regression decision tree and
the support vector machine let's start
with a closer look at linear regression
linear regression is perhaps one of the
most well-known and well-understood
algorithms in statistics and machine
learning linear regression is a linear
model for example a model that assumes a
linear relationship between the input
variables x and the single output
variable y
and you'll see this if you remember from
your algebra classes y equals mx plus c
imagine we are predicting distance
traveled y from speed x our linear
regression model representation for this
problem would be y equals m times x plus
c or distance equals m times speed plus
c where m is the coefficient and c is
the y-intercept and we're going to look
at two different variations of this
first we're going to start with time is
constant and you can see we have a
bicyclist he's got a safety gear on
thank goodness
speed equals 10 meters per second and so
over a certain amount of time his
distance equals 36 kilometers we have a
second bicyclist he's going twice the
speed or 20 meters per second and you
can guess if he's going twice the speed
and time is a constant then he's going
to go twice the distance and that's easy
to compute 36 times 2 you get 72
kilometers and so if you had the
question of how fast would somebody is
going three times at speed or 30 meters
per second is you can easily compute the
distance in our head we can do that
without needing a computer but we want
to do this for more complicated data so
it's kind of nice to compare the two but
let's just take a look at that and what
that looks like in a graph
so in a linear regression model we have
our distance to the speed and we have
our m equals the ve slope of the line
and we'll notice that the line has a
plus slope and as the speed increases
distance also increases hence the
variables have a positive relationship
and so your speed of the person which
equals y equals mx plus c distance
traveled in a fixed interval of time and
we could very easily compute either
following the line or just knowing it's
three times 10 meters per second that
this is roughly 102 kilometers distance
that this third bicyclist has traveled
one of the key
definitions on here is positive
relationship so the slope of the line is
positive as distance increase so does
speed increase let's take a look at our
second example where we put distance is
a constant so we have speed equals 10
meters per second they have a certain
distance to go and it takes him 100
seconds to travel that distance and we
have our second bicyclist who's still
doing 20 meters per second since he's
going twice the speed we can guess that
he'll cover the distance in about half
the time 50 seconds and of course you
could probably guess on the third one
100 divided by 30 since he's going three
times the speed you can easily guess
that this is 33.333
seconds time we put that into a linear
regression model or graph if the
distance is assumed to be constant let's
see the relationship between speed and
time and as time goes up the amount of
speed to go that same distance goes down
so now your m equals a minus ve slope of
the line as the speed increases time
decreases hence the variable has a
negative relationship again there's our
definition positive relationship and
negative relationship depended on the
slope of the line and with a simple
formula like this
and even a significant amount of data
let's see with the mathematical
implementation of linear regression and
we'll take this data so suppose we have
this data set where we have x y x equals
1 2 3 four five standard series and the
y value is three two two four three when
we take that and we go ahead and plot
these points on a graph you can see
there's kind of a nice scattering and
you could probably eyeball a line
through the middle of it but we're going
to calculate that exact line for linear
regression and the first thing we do is
we come up here we have the mean of x i
and remember mean is basically the
average so we added 5 plus 4 plus 3 plus
2 plus 1 and divide by 5.
that simply comes out as 3 and then
we'll do the same for y we'll go ahead
and add up all those numbers and divide
by 5 and we end up with the mean value
of y of i equals 2.8 where the x i
references it's an average or means
value and the y i also equals a means
value of y and when we plot that you'll
see that we can put in the y equals 2.8
and the x equals 3 in there on our graph
we kind of give it a little different
color so you could sort it out with the
dashed lines on it and it's important to
note that when we do the linear
regression the linear regression model
should go through that dot now let's
find our regression equation to find the
best fit line remember we go ahead and
take our y equals mx plus c so we're
looking for m and c so to find this
equation for our data we need to find
our slope of m and our coefficient of c
and we have y equals mx plus c where m
equals the sum of x minus x average
times y minus y average or y means and x
means over the sum of x minus x means
squared that's how we get the slope of
the value of the line and we can easily
do that by creating some columns here we
have x y computers are really good about
iterating through data and so we can
easily compute this and fill in a graph
of data and in our graph you can easily
see that if we have our x value of 1 and
if you remember the x i or the means
value is 3 1 minus 3 equals a negative 2
and 2 minus 3 equals a negative 1 so on
and so forth and we can easily fill in
the column of x minus x i y minus y i
and then from those we can compute x
minus x i squared and x minus x i times
y minus y i and you can guess it that
the next step is to go ahead and sum the
different columns for the answers we
need so we get a total of 10 for our x
minus x i squared and a total of 2 for x
minus x i times y minus y i and we plug
those in we get 2 10 which equals 0.2 so
now we know the slope of our line equals
0.2 so we can calculate the value of c
that'd be the next step is we need to
know where it crosses the y-axis and if
you remember i mentioned earlier that
the linear regression line has to pass
through the means value the one that we
showed earlier we can just flip back up
there to that graph and you can see
right here there's our means value which
is 3
x equals 3 and y equals 2.8 and since we
know that value we can simply plug that
into our formula y equals 0.2 x plus c
so we plug that in we get 2.8 equals 0.2
times 3 plus c and you can just solve
for c so now we know that our
coefficient equals 2.2 and once we have
all that we can go ahead and plot our
regression line y equals 0.2 times x
plus 2.2 and then from this equation we
can compute
new values so let's predict the values
of y using x equals 1 2 3 4 5 and plot
the points remember the 1 2 3 4 5 was
our original x values so now we're going
to see what y thinks they are not what
they actually are and we plug those in
we get y of designated with y of p you
can see that x equals 1 equals 2.4 x
equals 2 equals 2.6 and so on and so on
so we have our y predicted values of
what we think is going to be when we
plug those numbers in and when we plot
the predicted values along with the
actual values we can see the difference
and this is one of the things that's
very important with linear regression in
any of these models is to understand the
error and so we can calculate the error
on all of our different values and you
can see over here we plotted x and y and
y predict and we draw a little line so
you can sort of see what the error looks
like there between the different points
so our goal is to reduce this error we
want to minimize that error value on our
linear regression model minimizing the
distance there are lots of ways to
minimize the distance between the line
and the data points like sum of squared
errors sum of absolute errors root mean
square error etc we keep moving this
line through the data points to make
sure the best fit line has the least
square distance between the data points
and the regression line so to recap with
a very simple linear regression model we
first figure out the formula of our line
through the middle and then we slowly
adjust the line to minimize the error
keep in mind this is a very simple
formula the math gets even though the
math is very much the same it gets much
more complex as we add in different
dimensions so this is only two
dimensions y equals mx plus c but you
can take that out to x z i j q all the
different features in there and they can
plot a linear regression model on all of
those using the different formulas to
minimize the error let's go ahead and
take a look at decision trees a very
different way to solve problems in the
linear regression model decision tree is
a tree shaped algorithm used to
determine a course of action each branch
of a tree represents a possible decision
occurrence or reaction we have data
which tells us if it is a good day to
play golf and if we were to open this
data up in a general spreadsheet you can
see we have the outlook whether it's a
rainy overcast sunny temperature
hot mild cool humidity windy and did i
like to play golf that day yes or no so
we're taking a census and certainly i
wouldn't want a computer telling me when
i should go play golf or not but you can
imagine if you got up in the night
before you're trying to plan your day
and it comes up and says tomorrow would
be a good day for golf for you in the
morning and not a good day in the
afternoon or something like that this
becomes very beneficial and we see this
in a lot of applications coming out now
where it gives you suggestions and lets
you know what would be fit the match for
you for the next day or the next
purchase or the next whatever you know
next mail out in this case is tomorrow a
good day for playing golf based on the
weather coming in and so we come up and
let's uh determine if you should play
golf when the day is sunny and windy so
we found out the forecast tomorrow is
going to be sunny and windy and suppose
we draw our tree like this we're going
to have our humidity and then we have
our normal which is if it's if you have
a normal humidity you're going to go
play golf and if the humidity is really
high then we look at the outlook and if
the outlook is sunny overcast or rainy
it's going to change what you choose to
do so if you know that it's a very high
humidity and it's sunny you're probably
not going to play golf because you're
going to be out there miserable fighting
off the mosquitoes that are out joining
you to play golf with you maybe if it's
raining you probably don't want to play
in the rain but if it's slightly
overcast you get just the right
shadow that's a good day to play golf
and be outside out on the green now in
this example you can probably make your
own tree pretty easily because it's a
very simple set of data going in but the
question is how do you know what to
split where do you split your data what
if this is much more complicated data
where it's not something that you would
particularly understand
like studying cancer they take about 36
measurements of the cancerous cells and
then each one of those measurements
represents how bulbous it is how
extended it is how sharp the edges are
something that as a human we would have
no understanding of so how do we decide
how to split that data up and is that
the right decision tree but so the
question is going to come up is this the
right decision tree for that we should
calculate entropy and information gain
two important vocabulary words there are
the entropy and the information gain
entropy entropy is a measure of
randomness or impurity in the data set
entropy should be low so we want the
chaos to be as low as possible we don't
want to look at it and be confused by
the images or what's going on there with
mixed data and the information gain it
is a measure of decrease in entropy
after the data set is split also known
as entropy reduction information gain
should be high so we want our
information that we get out of the split
to be as high as possible let's take a
look at entropy from the mathematical
side in this case we're going to denote
entropy as i of p of and n where p
is the probability that you're going to
play a game of golf and n is the
probability where you're not going to
play the game of golf now you don't
really have to memorize these formulas
there's a few of them out there
depending on what you're working with
but it's important to note that this is
where this formula is coming from so
when you see it you're not lost when
you're running your programming unless
you're building your own decision tree
code in the back and we simply have a
log squared of p over p plus n minus n
over p plus n times the log squared of n
of p plus n but let's break that down
and see what actually looks like when
we're computing that from the computer
script side entropy of a target class of
the data set is the whole entropy so we
have entropy play golf and we look at
this if we go back to the data you can
simply count how many yeses and no in
our complete data set for playing golf
days in our complete set we find we have
five days we did play golf and nine days
we did not play golf and so our i equals
if you add those together nine plus five
is fourteen and so our i equals five
over fourteen and nine over fourteen
that's our p and n values that we plug
into that formula and you can go 5 over
14 equals 0.36 9 over 14 equals 0.64 and
when you do the whole equation you get
the minus 0.36 log root squared of 0.36
minus 0.64 log squared root of 0.64 and
we get a set value we get
0.94 so we now have a full entropy value
for the whole set of data that we're
working with and we want to make that
entropy go down and just like we
calculated the entropy out for the whole
set we can also calculate entropy for
playing golf and the outlook is it going
to be overcast or rainy or sunny and so
we look at the entropy we have p of
sunny times e of 3 of two and that just
comes out how many sunny days yes and
how many sunny days no over the total
which is five don't forget to put the
we'll divide that five out later on
equals p overcast equals four comma zero
plus rainy equals two comma three and
then when you do the whole setup we have
five over fourteen remember i said there
was a total of five five over fourteen
times the i of three of two plus four
over fourteen times the four comma zero
and 514 over i of 2 3. and so we can now
compute the entropy of just the part
that has to do with the forecast and we
get 0.693
similarly we can calculate the entropy
of other predictors like temperature
humidity and wind and so we look at the
gain outlook how much are we going to
gain from this entropy play golf minus
entropy play golf outlook and we can
take the original 0.94 for the whole set
minus the entropy of just the
rainy day and temperature and we end up
with a gain of 0.247
so this is our information gain remember
we define entropy and we define an
information gain the higher the
information gain the lower the entropy
the better the information gain of the
other three attributes can be calculated
in the same way so we have our gain for
temperature equals 0.029
we have our gain for humidity equals
0.152 and our gain for a windy day
equals 0.048 and if you do a quick
comparison you'll see the 0.247
is the greatest gain of information so
that's the split we want
now let's build the decision tree so we
have the outlook is it going to be sunny
overcast or rainy that's our first split
because that gives us the most
information gain and we can continue to
go down the tree using the different
information gains with the largest
information we can continue down the
nodes of the tree where we choose the
attribute with the largest information
gain as the root node and then continue
to split each sub node with the largest
information gain that we can compute and
although it's a little bit of a tongue
twister to say all that you can see
that's a very easy to view visual model
we have our outlook we split it three
different directions if the outlook is
overcast we're going to play and then we
can split those further down if we want
so if the outlook is sunny but then it's
also windy if it's windy we're not going
to play if it's not windy we'll play so
we can easily build a nice decision tree
to guess what we would like to do
tomorrow and give us a nice
recommendation for the day so we want to
know if it's a good day to play golf
when it's sunny and windy remember the
original question that came out
tomorrow's weather report is sunny and
windy you can see by going down the tree
we go outlook sunny outlook windy we're
not going to play golf tomorrow so our
little smart watch pops up and says i'm
sorry tomorrow's not a good day for golf
it's going to be sunny and windy and if
you're a huge golf fan you might go uh
oh
it's not a good day to play golf we can
go in and watch a golf game at home so
we'll sit in front of the tv instead of
being out playing golf in the wind
now that we looked at our decision tree
let's look at the third one of our
algorithms we're investigating support
vector machine support vector machine is
a widely used classification algorithm
the idea of support vector machine is
simple the algorithm creates a
separation line which divides the
classes in the best possible manner for
example dog or cat disease or no disease
suppose we have a labeled sample data
which tells height and weight of males
and females
a new data point arrives and we want to
know whether it's going to be a male or
a female so we start by drawing a line
we draw decision lines but if we
consider decision line 1 then we will
classify the individual as a male and if
we consider decision line 2 then it will
be a female so you can see this person
kind of lies in the middle of the two
groups so it's a little confusing trying
to figure out which line they should be
under we need to know which line divides
the classes correctly but how the goal
is to choose a hyper playing and that is
one of the key words they use when we
talk about support vector machines
choose a hyperplane with the greatest
possible margin between the decision
line and the nearest point within the
training set
so you can see here we have our support
vector we have the two nearest points to
it and we draw a line between those two
points and the distance margin is the
distance between the hyperplane and the
nearest data point from either set so we
actually have a value and it should be
equal the distance between the two
points that we're comparing it to when
we draw the hyperplanes we observe that
line one has a maximum distance so we
observe that line one has a maximum
distance margin so we'll classify the
new data point correctly and our result
on this one is going to be that the new
data point is mel one of the reasons we
call it a hyperplane versus a line
is that a lot of times we're not looking
at just weight and height we might be
looking at 36 different features or
dimensions and so when we cut it with a
hyperplane it's more of a
three-dimensional cut in the data
multi-dimensional it cuts the data a
certain way and each plane continues to
cut it down until we get the best fit or
match let's understand this with the
help of an example problem statement i
always start with a problem statement
when you're going to put some code
together we're going to do some coding
now classifying muffin and cupcake
recipes using support vector machines so
the cupcake versus the muffin let's have
a look at our data set and we have the
different recipes here we have a muffin
recipe that has so much flour i'm not
sure what measurement 55 is in but it
has 55 maybe it's ounces
but has a certain amount of flour
certain amount of milk sugar butter egg
baking powder vanilla and salt and so
based on these measurements we want to
guess whether we're making a muffin or a
cupcake and you can see in this one we
don't have just two features we don't
just have height and weight as we did
before between the male and female in
here we have a number of features
in fact in this we're looking at eight
different features to guess whether it's
a muffin or a cupcake
what's the difference between a muffin
and a cupcake turns out muffins have
more flour while cupcakes have more
butter and sugar so basically the
cupcakes a little bit more of a dessert
where the muffins a little bit more of a
fancy bread but how do we do that in
python how do we code that to go through
recipes and figure out what the recipe
is
and i really just want to say cupcakes
versus muffins like some big
professional wrestling thing before we
start in our cupcakes versus muffins we
are going to be working in python
there's many versions of python many
different editors that is one of the
strengths and weaknesses of python is it
just has so much stuff attached to it
it's one of the more popular data
science programming packages you can use
in this case we're going to go ahead and
use anaconda in jupiter nope the
anaconda navigator has all kinds of fun
tools once you're into the anaconda
navigator you can change environments i
actually have a number of environments
on here we'll be using python 3 6
environment so this is in python version
3.6 although it doesn't matter too much
which version you use
i usually try to stay with the 3x
because they're current unless you have
a project that's very specifically in
version 2x 27 i think is usually what
most people use in the version 2. and
then once we're in our
jupiter notebook editor i can go up and
create a new file and we'll just jump in
here
in this case we're doing svm muffin
versus cupcake and then let's start with
our packages
for
data analysis
and we almost always use a cup there's a
few very standard packages we use we use
import import import
numpy
that's for number python they usually
denote it as np that's very comma
that's very common
and then we're going to import pandas as
pd
and numpy deals with number arrays
there's a lot of cool things you can do
with the numpy
setup
as far as multiplying all the values in
an array in a numpy array data array
pandas
i can't remember if we're using it
actually in this data set i think we do
as an import it makes a nice data frame
and the difference between a data frame
and a numpy array is that a data frame
is more like your excel spreadsheet you
have columns you have indexes you have
different ways of referencing it easily
viewing it and there's additional
features you can run on a data frame and
pandas kind of sits on numpy so you need
them both in there
and then finally we're working with the
support vector machine so
from
sk learn we're going to use the sk learn
model
import svm support vector machine
and then as a data scientist you should
always try to visualize your data some
data obviously is too complicated or
doesn't make any sense to the human but
if it's possible it's good to take a
second look at it so you can actually
see what you're doing now for that we're
going to use two packages we're going to
import
matplotlibrary.piplot as plt
again very common
and we're going to import seaborn as sns
and we'll go ahead and set the font
scale in the sns right in our import
line that's what this
semicolon followed by a line of data
we're going to set the sns and these are
great because the the seaborn sits on
top of matplot library just like pandas
hits on numpy so it adds a lot more
features and uses and control we're
obviously not going to get into matplot
library and cborn it'd be its own
tutorial we're really just focusing on
the svm the support vector machine from
sklearn and since we're in jupiter
notebook
we have to add a special line in here
for our matplot library and that's your
percentage sign or ambersign matplot
library in line
now if you're doing this in just a
straight code project a lot of times i
use like notepad plus plus and i'll run
it from there you don't have to have
that line in there because it'll just
pop up as its own window on your
computer depending on how your
computer's set up because we're running
this in the jupyter notebook as a
browser setup this tells it to display
all of our graphics right below on the
page so that's what that line is for i
remember the first time i ran this i
didn't know that i had to go look that
up years ago it's quite a headache so
matplot library inline is just because
we're running this on the web setup and
we can go ahead and run this make sure
all our modules are in they're all
imported which is great if you don't
have an import you'll need to go ahead
and pip use the pip or however you do it
there's a lot of other install packages
out there although pip is the most
common and you have to make sure these
are all installed on your python setup
the next step of course is we got to
look at the data can't run a model for
predicting data if you don't have actual
data so to do that let me go and open
this up and take a look and we have our
cupcakes versus muffins
and it's a csv file or dot csv meaning
that it's comma separated variable
and it's going to open it up in a nice
spreadsheet for me and you can see up
here we have the type we have muffin
muffin muffin cupcake cupcake cupcake
and then it's broken up into flour milk
sugar butter egg baking powder vanilla
and salt
so we can do is we can go ahead and look
at this data also
in our python
let us create a variable recipes equals
we're going to use our pandas module
dot read
csv remember is a comma separated
variable
and the file name happened to be
cupcakes versus muffins oops i got
double brackets there
do it this way
there we go cupcakes versus muffins
because the program i loaded or the the
place i saved this particular python
program is in the same folder we get by
with just the file name but remember if
you're storing it in a different
location you have to also put down the
full path on there
and then because we're in pandas
we're going to go ahead and you can
actually inline you can do this but let
me do the full print you can just type
in recipes.head
in the jupiter notebook but if you're
running in code in a different script
you need to go ahead and type out the
whole print recipes dot head
and panda's nose is that's gonna do the
first five lines of data and if we flip
back on over to the spreadsheet where we
opened up our csv file
you can see where it starts on line two
this one calls it zero and then
two three four five six is going to
match
go and close that out because we don't
need that anymore
and it always starts at zero
and these are it automatically indexes
it since we didn't tell it to use an
index in here so that's the index number
for the left-hand side and it
automatically took the top row
as labels so pandas
using it to read a csv is just really
slick and fast one of the reasons we
love our pandas
not just because they're cute and cuddly
teddy bears
and let's go ahead and plot
our data
and i'm not going to plot all of it i'm
just going to plot the
sugar and flour
now obviously
you can see where they get really
complicated if we have tons of different
features
and so you'll break them up and maybe
look at just two of them at a time to
see how they connect
and to plot them we're going to go ahead
and use seaborn
so that's our sns
and the command for that is sns.lm plot
and then the two different variables i'm
going to plot is flour and sugar
data equals recipes
the hue equals type
and this is a lot of fun because it
knows that this is pandas coming in
so this is one of the powerful things
about pandas mixed with seabourn in
doing
graphing
and then we're going to use a palette
set one there's a lot of different sets
in there you can go look them up for
seabourn or do a regular fit regular
equals false so we're not really trying
to fit anything
and it's a scatter kws
a lot of these settings you can look up
in seabourn half of these you could
probably leave off when you run them
somebody played with this and found out
that these were the best settings for
doing a seaborn plot
let's go ahead and run that
and because it does it in line it just
puts it right on the page
and you can see right here that just
based on sugar and flour alone
there's a definite split
and we use these models because you can
actually look at and say hey if i drew a
line right between the middle of the
blue dots and the red dots
we'd be able to do an svm and a hyper
plane right there in the middle
then the next step is to
format or pre-process
our data
and we're going to break that up into
two parts
we need a type
label and remember we're going to decide
whether it's a muffin or cupcake well a
computer doesn't know muffin or cupcake
it knows zero and one
so what we're going to do is we're going
to create a type label
and from this we'll create a numpy array
and p
where
and this is where we can do some logic
we take our recipes from our panda
and wherever type equals muffin it's
going to be 0 and then if it doesn't
equal muffin which is cupcakes it's
going to be 1. so we create our type
label
this is the answer so when we're doing
our training model remember we have to
have a training data this is what we're
going to train it with is that it's 0 or
one it's a muffin or it's not
and then we're going to create our
recipe
features
and if you remember correctly from right
up here the first column is type
so we really don't need the type columns
that's our muffin or cupcake
and in pandas we can easily sort that
out
we take our value recipes
dot
columns that's a pandas function built
into pandas
we've got values converting them to
values so it's just the column titles
going across the top
and we don't want the first one so what
we do is it always starts at zero we
want
one colon till the end
and then
we want to go ahead and make this a list
and this converts it to a list of
strings
and then we can go ahead and just take a
look and see we're looking at for the
features make sure it looks right
let me go ahead and run that
and i forgot the s on recipes so we'll
go ahead and add the s in there and then
run that and we can see we have flour
milk sugar butter egg
baking powder vanilla and salt and that
matches what we have up here right where
we printed out everything but the type
so we have our features and we have our
label
now the recipe features is just the
titles of the columns and we actually
need
the ingredients
and at this point we have a couple
options one we could run it over all the
ingredients
and when you're doing this usually you
do but for our example we want to limit
it so you can easily see what's going on
because if we did all the ingredients
we have you know that's what
seven eight different hyper planes that
would be built into it we only want to
look at one so you can see what the svm
is doing
and so we'll take our recipes and we'll
do just flour and sugar
again you can replace that with your
recipe features and do all of them but
we're going to do just flour and sugar
and we're going to convert that to
values
we don't need to make a list out of it
because it's not string values these are
actual
values on there and we can go ahead and
just print
ingredients you can see what that looks
like
uh and so we have just the amount of
flour and sugar just the two sets of
plots
and just for fun let's go ahead and take
this over here and
take our recipe features
and so if we decided to use all the
recipe features
you'll see that it makes a nice column
of different data so it just strips out
all the labels and everything we just
have just the values
but because we want to be able to view
this easily in a plot later on we'll go
ahead and take that and just do flower
and sugar
and we'll run that you'll see it's just
the two columns
so the next step is to go ahead and fit
our model
we'll go ahead and just call it model
and it's a svm we're using a package
called svc
in this case we're going to go ahead and
set the kernel equals linear so it's
using a specific set up on there and if
we go to the reference on their website
for the svm
you'll see that there's about there's
eight of them here
three of them are for regression
three are for classification the svc
support vector classification is
probably one of the most commonly used
and then there's also one for detecting
outliers
and another one that has to do with
something a little bit more specific on
the model but svc and sbr are the two
most commonly used standing for support
vector classifier and support vector
regression remember regression is an
actual value a float value or
whatever you're trying to work on and
sbc is a classifier so it's a yes no
true false
but for this we want to know zero one
muffin cupcake
we go ahead and create our model and
once we have our model created we're
going to do model.fit and this is very
common especially in the sk learn all
their models are followed with the fit
command
and what we put into the fit what we're
training with it is we're putting in the
ingredients which in this case we
limited to just flour and sugar
and the type label is it a muffin or
cupcake
now in more complicated data science
series you'd want to split into we won't
get into that today we split it into uh
training data and test data and they
even do something where they split it
into thirds where a third is used for
when you switch between which one's
training and test there's all kinds of
things go into that it gets very
complicated when you get to the higher
end not overly complicated just an extra
step which we're not going to do today
because this is a very simple set of
data
and let's go ahead and run this and now
we have our model fit
and i got a error here so let me fix
that real quick capital svc it turns out
i did it lower case
support vector
classifier there we go let's go ahead
and run that
and you'll see it comes up with all this
information that it prints out
automatically these are the defaults of
the model
you notice that we change the kernel to
linear and there's our kernel linear on
the printout and there's other different
settings you can mess with
we're going to just leave that alone for
right now for this we don't really need
to mess with any of those
so next we're going to dig a little bit
into our newly trained model
and we're going to do this so we can
show you on a graph
let's go ahead and get the separating
and we're going to say we're going to
use a w for our variable on here
we're going to do model
dot coefficient underscore zero
so what the heck is that again we're
digging into the model so we've already
got a prediction and a train
this is a math behind it that we're
looking at right now
and so
the w is going to represent two
different coefficients and if you
remember we had y equals mx plus c
so these coefficients are connected to
that
but in two dimensional it's a plane
we don't want to spend
too much time on this because you can
get lost in the confusion of the math so
if you're a math whiz this is great you
can go through here and you'll see that
we have a equals minus w0 over w of one
remember there's two different values
there
and that's basically
the slope that we're generating
and then we're going to build an xx what
is xx we're going to set it up to a
numpy array there's our np dot line
space
so we're creating a line
of values between 30 and 60. so it just
creates a set of numbers for x
and then if you remember correctly we
have
our formula y equals the slope times x
plus the intercept well to make this
work we can do this as y y
equals the slope times each value in
that array
that's the neat thing about numpy so
when i do a times xx which is a whole
numpy array of values it multiplies a
across all of them
and then it takes those same values and
we subtract the model intercept let's
your uh
where we had mx plus c so that'd be the
c from the formula y equals mx plus c
and that's where all these numbers come
from a little bit confusing because it's
digging out of these different arrays
and then we want to do is we're going to
take this and we're going to go ahead
and plot it
so plot the parallels to separating
hyperplane that pass through the support
vectors
and so we're going to create b equals a
model
support vectors
pulling our support vectors out there
here's our y y which we now know is a
set of data and we have uh we're going
to create y y down
equals a times x x plus
b 1 minus a times b 0
and then model support vector b is going
to be set that to a new value the minus
1 set up and y y up equals a times x x
plus b 1 minus a times b 0.
and we can go ahead and just run this to
load these variables up if you want to
know understand a little bit more of
what's going on you can see if we print
y y let me just run that
you can see it's an array this is a line
it's going to have in this case between
30 and 60 so it's going to be 30
variables in here
and the same thing with yy up yy down
and we'll plot those in just a minute on
the graph so you can see what those look
just like ahead and delete that out of
here
and run that so it loads up the
variables nice clean slate
i'm just going to copy this from before
remember this our sns
our seaborn plot lm plot flower sugar
and i'll just go ahead and run that real
quick so you can see remember what that
looks like it's just a straight graph on
there
and then one of the neat things is
because seaborne sits on top of pie plot
we can do the pie plot for the line
going through and that is simply plt dot
plot
and that's our x x
and y y are two corresponding values x y
and then somebody played with this to
figure out that the line width equals
two in the color black would look nice
so let's go ahead and run this whole
thing with the pie plot on there and you
can see when we do this it's just doing
flour and sugar on here
corresponding line between the sugar and
the flour and the muffin versus cupcake
and then we generated the
support vectors the y y down and y y up
so let's take a look and see what that
looks
like so we'll do our pl plot
and again this is all against x x
or our x value but this time we have y y
down
and let's do something a little fun with
this we can put in a k
dash dash
that just tells it to make it a dotted
line
and if we're going to do the down one
we also want to do the up one
so here's our yy
up
and when we run that it both sets a line
and so here's our support and this is
what you expect you expect these two
lines to go through the nearest data
point so the dashed lines go through the
nearest muffin and the nearest cupcake
when it's plotting it and then your svm
goes right down the middle so it gives
it a nice split in our data and you can
see how easy it is to see based just on
sugar and flour
which one's a muffin or a cupcake
let's go ahead and create a function
to predict
muffin or cupcake
got my
recipes i pulled off the
internet and i want to see the
difference between a
muffin or a cupcake and so we need a
function to push that through
and create a function with depth and
let's call it muffin or cupcake and
remember we're just doing flour and
sugar today we're not doing all the
ingredients
and that actually is a pretty good split
you really don't need all the
ingredients you know it's flour and
sugar
and let's go ahead and do an if else
statement so if model predict
is of flour and sugar equals zero
so we take our model and we do it run a
predict it's very common in sk learn we
have a dot predict you put the data in
and it's going to return a value in this
case if it equals zero then print you're
looking at a muffin recipe
else if it's not zero that means it's
one then you're looking at a cupcake
recipe
that's pretty straightforward for
function or def for definition def is
how you do that in python
and of course we're going to create a
function you should run something in it
and so let's run a cupcake and we're
going to send it values 50 and 20 a
muffin or cupcake i don't know what it
is
and let's run this and just see what it
gives us
and it says oh it's a muffin you're
looking at a muffin recipe
so it very easily predicts whether we're
looking at a muffin or a cupcake recipe
let's
plot this
there we go plot this on the graph so we
can see what that actually looks like
and i'm just going to copy and paste it
from below where we're plotting all the
points in there
so this is nothing different than we did
before if i run it you'll see it has all
the points and the lines on there and
what we want to do is we want to add
another point
and we'll do plt plot
and if you remember correctly we did for
our test we did 50 and 20.
and then somebody went in here and
decided we'll do a y-o for yellow or
it's kind of a oranges yellow color it's
going to come out marker size 9 those
are settings you can play with somebody
else played with them to come up with
the right setup so it looks good
and you can see there it is graphed
clearly a muffin
in this case in cupcakes versus muffins
the muffin has won
and if you'd like to do your own muffin
cupcake
contender series you certainly can send
a note down below and the team at
simplylearn will send you over the data
they use for the muffin and cupcake and
that's true of any of the data we didn't
actually run a plot on it earlier we had
men versus women
you can also request that information to
run it on your data setup so you can
test that out
so to go back over our setup we went
ahead for our support vector machine
code we did a predict 40 parts flower 20
parts sugar i think it was different
than the one we did whether it's a
muffin or a cupcake hence we have built
a classifier using svm which is able to
classify if a recipe is of a cupcake or
a muffin which wraps up our cupcake
versus muffin
so the key takeaways what is machine
learning we discussed that with some of
the different aspects of machine
learning on there we went into types of
machine learning if you memorize we have
supervised unsupervised and
reinforcement learning we discuss
regression line or best fit and we did
the building a decision tree and what
the logic is behind that
and finally we did classification using
svm support vector machine and we did
the code in there
that wraps it up i want to thank you for
joining us today for more information
visit www.simplylearn.com
get certified
get ahead and remember if you have any
questions feel free to visit us on our
website or post them here on the youtube
as we will be monitoring that we might
be able to answer those questions thank
you very much for joining us today and
happy learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here
you